a major contribution toward the
rehabilitation of amputees is made by
the physical therapy section let's
follow some new patients in the early
stages of treatment one concern of the
physical therapists is that of
maintaining normal joint range of motion
of the remaining lower extremity joints
this is accomplished by strict adherence
to proper bed positioning and through
the use of active range of motion
exercises
our hip flexion abduction external
rotation contracture is typical in the
above knee amputee with the pelvis level
the above knee stump should be
positioned in adduction and extension
this can best be accomplished with the
amputee lying prone
active exercises to the hip extensors
and hip adductors help to maintain
muscle tone full excursion of hip
abduction and flexion is delayed until
the severed muscle groups have
sufficiently reattached
the Bologna stump should be maintained
in extension quadriceps setting
exercises aid in maintaining full knee
extension avoidance of prolonged periods
of sitting for the use of pillows is
important in preventing the development
of muscular imbalance and subsequent
joint contractures proper stump
bandaging is necessary for shaping and
shrinking the stump before the
artificial limb is fitted stump
bandaging should be started early and be
continued until a prosthesis is used
throughout the day for the
above-the-knee amputee the sideline
position allows the stump to be wrapped
in extension to aid in preventing a hip
flexion contracture a 6-inch bandage is
anchored about the waist providing a
base for additional bandages
to four-inch bandages with recurrent and
spiral turns are used to shape the stump
firm pressure is applied throughout the
process with slightly more pressure
exerted distally than proximally an
adductor roll causes improper fitting of
the stump into the prosthesis an
effective method of preventing the
development of an adductor roll is to
wrap the hip Spica high into the groin
this is the most critical aspect of
wrapping the above the knees stump
the final bandage is crossed posteriorly
to maintain hip extension and pinned to
prevent slipping
in wrapping the below-the-knee stump to
four inch bandages can be used one
bandages started by making three
recurrent turns
these are anchored by spiral rather than
circular turns to avoid choking of the
stump
the second bandage utilizes recurrence
from the lateral to the medial aspects
of the stump
the bandage is secured above the knee
and should include the femoral condyles
as these are contained within the
patellar tendon bearing prostheses an
automobile accident necessitated the
amputation of this patient's left lower
extremity above the knee and his right
lower extremity below the knee he now
wears a quadrilateral total contact
suction socket prosthesis on the left
leg and if a teller tendon bearing
prosthesis on the right
a program of mat exercises is used
before the patient is to be fitted with
his prosthesis such a program helps to
improve strength coordination balance
and endurance of the involved
extremities and the body as a whole the
hip abductors may be shortened and
weakened if there is a typical
contracture of the above-the-knee stump
this strengthening exercise may prevent
a gluteus medius limb
strengthening of the hip adductors
assists in preventing the abducted
posture of the above the knee stump
the hip extensors are vital in
prosthetic control such an exercise may
also prevent a hip flexion contracture
exercises for both trunk and hip
extensors afford a general
reconditioning activity which can be
done independently ball balancing
enhances body balance and coordination
and helps to develop a kinesthetic
awareness of an altered center of
gravity
by placing the below-the-knee stamp
against the ball for resistance to the
hamstrings the patient finds another
means of exercising independently this
is an important factor when designing a
mat program for a group of amputees the
development of the upper extremities
through weight lifting techniques is an
important part of the amputees pre
prosthetic program
push-ups are initiated as a pre crutch
training activities
the ability to maintain balance can be
improved by resisting attempts to shift
the trunk beyond its base of support
ball throwing and catching with
deliberate efforts to throw the patient
off balance also improve trunk stability
functional activities which will help
the patient to become independent are
emphasized from the beginning of the mat
program here the amputee learns to get
from the mat to the wheelchair
unassisted
as the condition of the stump improves
mechanical pulley resistance may be
utilized to assist in developing muscle
strength the progressive resistance
exercise method as described by the
lorem is utilized here in exercising the
gluteus medius muscle
resistance to the gluteus maximus is
given within the range in which it is
required to be used in the above the
knee prosthesis
in addition to quadriceps resistive
exercises special emphasis is given to
hamstring strengthening because of the
importance of this muscle group in the
use of the patellar tendon bearing
prosthesis
good care of the stump skin is a vital
part of rehabilitation and can prevent
many complications which might delay
continued use of the prosthesis by the
patient a daily routine of stump
cleansing with a good white soap is
important
the stump should be thoroughly rinsed
proper drying will prevent irritation
and maceration of the skin stump
cleansing at night rather than in the
morning will eliminate the possibility
of damp skin sticking to the prosthesis
which tends to cause skin irritation
since the socket of the artificial limb
may itself produce a skin disorder
cleansing of the socket is as important
as care of the stump cleaning the valve
seat will help prevent air leakage
dirt or powder in the valve will result
in a poorly maintained vacuum depressing
the spring allows for thorough cleansing
of the valve and rubber gasket
this is the quadrilateral total contact
suction socket prosthesis it contains a
constant friction knee joint which can
readily be adjusted
the ischial seat provides the major
weight-bearing area this is the medial
brim the anterior medial corner of which
is the channel for the adductor longus
and grassless muscles the Scarpas bulge
and the high anterior and lateral walls
provide the necessary stability to force
the stump back onto the ischial seat
with the patellar tendon bearing
prosthesis the weight is born at the
midpoint of the patellar tendon the
popliteal bulge forces the stump forward
onto the weight-bearing surface the
socket is set in approximately 15
degrees of knee flexion initially the
prosthesis contains an adjustable shank
which allows periodic realignments to be
made before fitting the patient with the
final prosthesis both limbs are fitted
with a solid ankle cushion healed foot
or sach foot
prior to evaluation of the fit of the
artificial limb the patient is assisted
in putting the stump into the prosthesis
with a silk stocking
the stump must make total contact with
the wall of the prosthesis
the adductor longus muscles should fit
into the adductor Channel for proper
rotation alignment the pubic ramus is
checked for proper length of the medial
wall of the prosthesis firmness of the
skin above the prosthesis implies
adequate seating of the stump
level hips indicate appropriate length
of the prosthesis the tuberosity of the
ischium should ride on the ischial seat
the anterior brim of the above the knee
prosthesis should not contact the
anterior superior spine of the ilium in
forward bending of the trunk the upper
brim of the patellar tendon bearing
prosthesis bisects the patella utilizing
the cuff suspension to help maintain the
knee in flexion and to suspend the
prosthesis itself the cuff suspension
should be taught in standing
when sitting the cuff suspension should
be relaxed choking I'll be below the
knee stump occurs if the posterior wall
of the prosthesis is too high the
constant friction of this new unit is
inadequate because it permits excessive
freedom of the knee the mechanical
friction of the knee unit is constant
but adjustable the friction may be
increased or decreased by adjustment
with an Allen wrench adequate friction
is essential for knee stability in the
stance phase and proper timing in the
swing phase
here the patient applies his own
prosthesis a stump sock is used for the
patellar tendon bearing prosthesis
talcum powder is needed in applying the
suction socket prosthesis when the stump
itself perspires freely or is unusually
flat II
the stocking should be placed high on
the stump to prevent an excessive roll
of flesh above the brim of the
prosthesis after its applications
note the pumping action at the hip and
the steady pull on the stocking to
assist in getting the stump into the
prosthesis the valve should be well
seated
early gait training activities are
concerned with learning to balance on
the prosthetic legs with the pelvis and
shoulders level the patient shifts his
weight laterally first width and then
without hands and progresses to
balancing on one prosthetic leg
forward and backward shifting of weight
is practice
the patient advances to shifting his
entire body weight onto the forward legs
and stepping through with the opposite
leg
in using the above the knee prosthesis
the patient must learn two basic skills
first he must learn to swing the
prosthesis and timeless swing so that
completes knee extension comes just at
heel strike second he must learn to lock
the knee joint by extending the hip
there are also two basic skills to be
mastered with the patellar tendon
bearing prosthesis controlled knee
flexion from heel strike to foot flat
must first be practiced with the foot
flat as a base of support controlled
knee extension as the body weight is
shifted over the extremity is then
practiced
ball growing develops balanced
early recognition and correction of some
of the more common gait deviations is
necessary before a habit pattern is
established but causes can be many and
complete evaluation requires the clinic
team approach
one of the most frequently seen gate
faults in the above knee amputee is
lateral trunk bending toward the
amputated side it is often caused by
weakened or shortened hip abductors and
may be anticipated when the patient has
a very short stump another common gate
fault is heel whip the lateral heel whip
in this instance is related to improper
rotation alignment of the above knee
prosthesis as it was put on
the hip is often flexed excessively to
clear the prosthetic foot
circumduction of the prosthesis implies
that the limb may be too long
abduction of the prosthetic leg may
represent an effort to avoid full weight
bearing on the prosthetic side this
fault may be partially corrected by line
walking to force weight bearing on the
offending side
unequal step length is a common problem
which ordinarily can be corrected by
training
one frequent mistake in using the
patellar tendon bearing prosthesis is
hyperextension of the knee at heel
strike it is more often seen in amputees
who have previously worn a conventional
below the knee prosthesis hyperextension
of the knee can be related to failure to
decelerate the lower leg by hamstring
contraction
the correct relationship of the
prosthesis to the femur at heel strike
is approximately 10 degrees of flexion
properly done the knee should remain
flexed from heel strike through mid
stance
the patient begins ambulation out of the
parallel bars with the four-point crotch
gate
the two-point gait is a natural
progression as balance improves
finally the cane may be used for walking
on level surfaces
when walking on incline the patient
takes a shorter step with the above the
knee prosthesis in ascending ramps this
short step compensates for the limited
dorsi flexion of the foot in descending
ramps the shortened step prevents
buckling of the knee as weight is borne
on the above the knee prosthesis
at first the bilateral amputee can be
taught to get into and out of a chair by
pivoting as my two paraplegic the knee
of the suction socket prosthesis is
locked by contracting the hip extensors
the amputee since it's in the more
conventional manner with less hand
assistance and less attention to his
disability
as Falls happened suddenly the amputee
should be prepared to discard the
crutches break the fall with his hands
and roll with the fall in rising the
prosthetic left knee must be stable one
crutch is used for support
stair activities begin with handrail
assistance control descent is affected
one step at a time by the right knee
joint
in ascending again the right quadriceps
provides the muscular power for
elevation in observing the patient and
stair activities one can readily note
the advantages of having an intact knee
joint the patient demonstrates the
progression in which he learned to
negotiate stairs
these advanced functional skills
required time and sustained effort on
the amputees part and much depends upon
the individual patient's motivation
every service on the rehabilitation team
played an important role in returning
this man to duty the officer conducting
this briefing is continuing to fill an
important role in the defense of our
nation
you